Speaker 1: as we continue to see Russia's invasion
of Ukraine lead to hundreds plus casualties and
wreak global chaos. We have new polling data.
Who do Republicans like more leading Democrats
or authoritarian Vladimir Putin? I know, you
know the answer. They prefer Vladimir Putin.
Republicans view Putin more favorably than they
do leading Democrats. Washington Post reporting.
This is from YouGov. So if you look at the
favorability of leaders and parties overall,
you see that in the US, Biden is more favorably
looked at than Putin and more favorably looked
at than Trump. But Obama is more popular than
Biden. However, when you look at Republicans,
you see that Putin is actually seen as
slightly more favorable than Joe Biden.
The number the number of Republicans who say
Putin is very favorable is slightly higher
than the number who see Biden very favorably.
And the number of Republicans who see Putin
as somewhat favorable is significantly
higher than the portion that see Joe
Biden as somewhat favorable. Of course, they
love Trump and they love the Republican Party,
and they see Barack Obama very similarly
to how they see Vladimir Putin. They
prefer a foreign, authoritarian autocrat
who is antagonistic to the United States,
to Joe Biden. And this is the result
of very effective propaganda, very,
very effective propaganda. And I have to tell you,
it's been effective propaganda from the right.
And Democrats are really bad at these arguments.
Republicans are not impressive people. These are
not genuinely smart people, but they know how
to message effectively. They know how to put
money behind that messaging, and they're
crushing Democrats to the point where,
I mean, listen, yeah, well, I'm not going to
play the both sides game, you know, like, Oh, we
should blame the left for Trump. No, we should
primarily blame the people who voted for Trump.
And then we can also talk about ways in which
the Left has failed to respond to Trump fine.
And similarly, in this case, we can say the
left's counter-messaging hasn't been great
to the Republican propaganda, but the primarily
the Republican propaganda is to blame.
And remember, you have a Republican electorate
that is very vulnerable to that propaganda. And
this is also partially a result of the reality
that the people that they pander to are just less
likely to think critically or outside of their own
interests, and it just makes them a better target.
All of those things are true. And where it leads
us or where it leaves us, better, better said
is with Republicans preferring Putin to Biden as
Putin has launched a brutal invasion of Ukraine,
violating the sovereignty of its borders, which
Republicans claim to care about when it's the
US-Mexico border to our south. I mean, sad
doesn't even cover it, but it is very, very sad.